[Music]
on this wednesday night from quebec city
the second stop of the pope's pilgrimage
of penance the province's first visit
from a pontiff in four decades asking
forgiveness you know that's a big deal
and how quebecers are losing their
religion there's no other place in the
continent that is less practicing plus
the meaning
behind this woman's emotional message to
the pope hockey canada's hush money the
staggering amount of cash used to settle
decades of sexual misconduct claims and
first degree murder police arrest two
people accused of killing the man
acquitted of the air india bombings
global national with donna frieza
reporting tonight from quebec city jeff
semple
pope francis arriving here to the plains
of abraham in quebec city this evening
waving to hundreds of people who had
gathered here some since very early this
morning the pope arrived here from
edmonton for the next leg of what he
calls his pilgrimage of penance in
canada good evening and thank you for
joining us we are coming to you tonight
from the plains of abraham here in
quebec city's battlefields park an
historic site hosting a historic visit
from the pontiff hundreds of people had
gathered here to catch a glimpse of the
holy father and despite the painful
purpose of his visit it was really a
celebratory atmosphere here and that
continues tonight
in just a few short hours the pope met
with the prime minister the governor
general and residential school survivors
and he once again apologized begging for
forgiveness for the catholic church's
role in canada's residential school
system
i express my deep shame and sorrow
and together with the bishops of this
country
i renew my request for forgiveness for
the wrong done by so many christians to
the indigenous peoples
[Music]
i beg forgiveness
there's no doubt
that you had an enormous
impact
survivors and their descendants need to
be
at the center of everything we do
going
forward the prime minister there also
speaking today his first public
statements since the pope's trip began
they both spoke inside the citatel de
quebec that's an active military
installation and also the second
official residence of the governor
general of canada
now this marks pope francis's first stop
outside of alberta and into a province
that has deep roman catholic roots our
mike armstrong is following the pope on
this leg of his canadian tour so mike
the pope touched down at around three
o'clock local time this afternoon how
did events unfold from your vantage
point
well not without a couple of hiccups the
pope's plane arrived on time but another
plane carrying indigenous leaders and
members of the organizing committee had
trouble getting out of alberta actually
so the day's schedule had to be pushed
back an hour basically before it even
started people here in the plains of
abraham watched the arrival and events
on a big screen
but they did get to see the pope in
person when he made a last trip uh last
event of the day a trip in the
popemobile past the crowd here they're
also going to be showing by the way the
mass tomorrow that the pope will be
celebrating they're going to show it on
the big screen here it's happening
outside town but this will sort of be
overflow for people who can't make it to
saint and
jeff
right and speaking of overflow i didn't
have a chance to do a head count but
look like maybe a couple thousand people
in that crowd here today but certainly
nothing compared to the hundreds of
thousands we saw here during the last
papal visit 38 years ago so what's the
relationship these days like between
quebecers and the catholic church
yeah well if you go back 60 years this
was the most religious province in
canada it's actually the least religious
province now
even if it doesn't always feel that way
if you were dropped out of the sky into
quebec not knowing much about it you'd
likely maybe undoubtedly assume it's
deeply religious there are streets and
towns named after saints in every
direction and if you're in a place with
a mountain including montreal there's a
good chance there's a cross looking down
well as they say appearances can be
deceiving there's no other place in the
continent that is less practicing
than is quebec
this is a place where the catholic
church was once powerful and popular
back in the 1950s about 90 percent of
catholics attended church every week
in 1984 when pope john paul visited the
province church attendance was still
around 50
that number kept dropping today it's
about four percent
where the catholic church once
administered schools ran hospitals and
oversaw social welfare programs starting
in the 1960s quebec became more and more
secular
i think it was driven by politics
largely the idea that the modernization
of the province uh
actually required to push the church
aside
now there is a paradox in modern quebec
people may not attend church but
according to statistics canada it has
the highest rate of people who declare a
religious affiliation the vast majority
of
at least francophones were you know
baptized they became catholic
but it doesn't mean that today they they
still believe in the church
but they might still identify as
catholic
as part of their you know cultural
cultural identity
those religious symbols that are
everywhere in quebec are for many not a
part of their religion as much as their
heritage there have been calls to remove
the cross in montreal in the name of
secularism but there are also voices
that want to protect it in the name of
history
that said quebec's secularism push has
led to its controversial bill 21. it
bans some public sector employees from
wearing religious clothing like hijabs
and kippas or a visible cross around
someone's neck but something like the
cross over montreal is different
a lot of the crosses that you see here
are considered closer to something
secular
whereas
non-christian religious symbols are
certainly
described as religious and significantly
religious and even threatening on some
level
there's a new term that's been coined to
sort of describe how quebec straddles
being both religious and secular and
it's cato la icite catholic secularism
two terms that normally
don't really go together jeff
catholic secularism all right mike
armstrong who's with us here in quebec
city thanks mike and among those also in
attendance here a group of residential
school survivors along with their
friends and families who walked
275 kilometers to be here they began
their journey some seven days ago from
the inu community of mastuayash now
that's a symbolic starting point
masturias is where quebec's last
residential school closed in 1991. i met
one member of the march whose mother
attended that school and who later died
of alcoholism and he says this walk
itself is a symbolic healing journey
i think that's a very symbolic of the
the path that ancient people in canada
have to take
a long walk of that
of a journey of healing
and
and
we have to start from some somewhere
you have to do the first step
even if it's not perfect the second step
may be better the third step going to be
better and one going gonna arrive to the
thousand steps you're gonna be excellent
walker
and coming up a little later in the
newscast we'll explore the push to
preserve indigenous languages i'll speak
with one group of inuit on how they're
working to bring inukdit into the
digital age
and a reminder that if you or someone
you know who is a residential school
survivor are looking for help you can
call that residential school survivors
and family crisis line anytime it's
six
1-800-721-0066
to other news now and damning new
details about hockey canada's handling
of sexual assault allegations the
governing body paid out more than seven
million dollars in nine sex abuse
settlements dating back to the 1980s as
shalima maharaj reports mps now want to
know why the board hasn't been more
transparent
demands for a changing of the guard
front and center as hockey canada cfo
brian cairo admitted to settlement
payments from its national equity fund
nine settlement payments have been made
totaling 7.6 million dollars on top of
that another 12 sexual misconduct
settlements in the amount of 1.3 million
dollars through insurance the board of
directors authorized the maximum amount
of the settlement you've now stated that
the board authorized the maximum amount
where is that minuted in a board of
directors meeting
as i stated earlier in camera
sessions within the board for the board
of directors are not minuted there was
no mincing words former nhl or an
advocate for victim sheldon kennedy
reiterating his urgent call for hockey
canada ceo scott smith to step down it's
kind of like oh we got caught we better
do this because the minister tells us to
do this and our sponsors pulled out i
strongly believe there needs to be new
leadership within hockey canada will you
do that will you step down for new
leadership to take over that i'm
prepared to take on this responsibility
for change within our game i believe
i've got the experience to do it should
our board or the governance review that
we've outlined our action plan suggest
that i'm not the person that i'm
prepared to take on or to
prepare to accept that hockey's been
able to
maintain its operations
with practices that are not congruent
with the changes we've seen in broader
society and that's the change that needs
to take place the scandal surrounding
hockey canada's handling of alleged
sexual assaults has conjured a larger
conversation about canada's once beloved
national pastime this is an entire
cultural change that needs to happen
it needs to happen from top to bottom in
the organization
and putting out an action plan is not
going to be enough shaleema maharaj
global news ottawa
the canadian government says there are
now 745
confirmed cases of monkey pox in this
country and it expects that number to
climb
the public health agents of canada
recommends practicing safer sex
having fewer sexual partners
particularly anonymous partners even
when they don't have symptoms can also
reduce your risk of getting infected
canada's public health agency says it
has deployed more than 70 000 doses of a
vaccine to provinces and territories
globally 78 countries have reported more
than 18 000 cases of the disease and
last weekend the world health
organization declared monkey pox a
global health emergency
new developments in a murder
investigation coming up who's been
charged with killing the man acquitted
of the air india bombings
we are coming to you from the plains of
abraham in quebec city the national
traditional unseated territory of the
huron-wendat people and we'll be right
back
welcome back to quebec city we'll have
more on the pope's canadian visit in
just a moment but we turn now to a
developing story out of british columbia
two men there are facing charges tonight
in the murder of raputaman singh malik
the 75 year old was gunned down outside
his business earlier earlier this month
in surrey bc just east of vancouver
malik himself was acquitted of murder
charges in the 1985 air india bombings
as kamal karamali explains this isn't
the accused first run-in with the law
police announcing the arrest of two
males in their 20's nearly two weeks
after rapudaman singh mulik was gunned
down in a neighborhood in surrey b.c
twenty-one-year-old tanner fox and
twenty-three-year-old jose lopez have
been charged with first degree murder
arrested yesterday at their homes just
outside vancouver but both appear to
have a long history of violent crime
court records show a man with the same
name as fox was charged after a 2019
stabbing in abbotsford and an aggravated
assault last fall a man with the same
name as lopez shows a longer rap sheet
charged last summer with nine criminal
counts including possession of a firearm
the victim mullik a controversial
business figure in surrey most notably
known for being charged in the 1985 air
india bombing that killed 331 passengers
most of them from vancouver and toronto
he and another suspected co-conspirator
were acquitted in 2005. the 75 year old
was shot multiple times in a surrey
neighborhood on july 14th investigators
releasing a video of a suspect vehicle
that was found burned out hours after
the fatal shooting police say the public
was able to id that suspect vehicle that
led to the arrests but giving limited
details during a press conference today
including whether there's a connection
between the accused and victim if
they're searching for any more suspects
or if other suspects hired the two young
men the investigation is ongoing uh
obviously we're in the infancy of this
investigation as it's only 13 days old
so there's many follow-up tasks to be
completed
friends and family have told global news
they do not believe that this targeted
attack has anything to do with the air
india case meanwhile the two suspects
were set to appear in provincial court
today kamal karamali global news in
surrey british columbia
the cry heard across canada ahead the
woman behind this heart-wrenching moment
following the pope's apology
[Music]
welcome back to the plains of abraham in
quebec city this historic site that
hosted the final public event of the day
for pope francis and as you can hear a
concert continues here this evening on
monday the pontiff delivered his first
apology on canadian soil to residential
school survivors in moscow cheese
alberta but it was a moment that
followed his words that has garnered
global attention as the program with
pope francis drew to a close a woman's
voice could be heard singing over the
crowd it sounded like oh canada but
there was a deeper message behind her
performance heather york's west
introduces us to the woman behind the
emotional moments seen around the world
a fist raised to the sky a woman's voice
carrying over the crowd in song
this was musketee's monday the first day
of the papal tour
moments earlier pope francis had
apologized for generations of cruelty
and harm
but then
only that voice
its strength
and undeniable emotion
[Music]
to many it sounded like oh canada the
language to those who know it
unmistakably cree
her eyes seem to reveal so much pain
the final notes building
to a deep pride this wasn't part of the
program
and then still before the pope the woman
shouts
her words carrying so much passion i
turned my back i said hi height and i
shook it off that's enough because i
wouldn't let it hurt me anymore
her name is sapiko and she says what
she's saying in moscow cheese wasn't the
canadian anthem at all no that's not all
canada that's our village in the
language of the four winds after the
song i spoke the law to him the law of
these lands
served the spoken law we the daughters
of the great spirit and our tribal
sovereign members cannot be coerced into
any law or treaty that is not the great
law we have appointed chiefs on our
territories convert yourselves
accordingly her spontaneous moment of
courage has been met with praise from
both those who were there and the
millions more who watched from afar
sapiko says the pain she felt that day
was shared and not hers alone
when she finished she let that pain
go
yeah it felt powerful everybody that was
hurting through this residential school
everybody that shared their stories with
me that's who i shook my fringes to free
them from all the pain that's what i
felt
a deeply personal and burdening
still echoing across canada and around
the world
heather yorick's west global news
edmonton
meets the internet next the digital
drive to protect an indigenous language
for future generations
[Music]
the pope will leave quebec and head to
ocala on friday where he'll speak with
some of nunavut's residential school
survivors many of whom say they were
beaten and abused just for speaking
their own language today there are more
than 70 indigenous languages spoken
across canada though many of those are
considered endangered by the u.n on a
recent trip to nunavut's capital i met
with a group of inuit who are now
working to protect their language in the
age of social media
summer in ocala wheat is in full swing
[Music]
was hosting a celebration of inuit
culture from food to music but in a
territory where inuktitut is an official
language a lot of residents could also
be heard speaking and singing in english
what language are you speaking mostly
mostly english i'm not fluent in
inuktitut while inuktitut is spoken more
than many indigenous languages the
mother tongue of around 60 of nunavut's
population is in decline more and more
children are speaking more english the
group that represents inuit in nunavut
says at this rate by the year 2050
inuktitut will only be spoken by four
percent of households
she points to a new french language
school being built with federal funds
well inuktitut is only taught here up to
grade four we're treated so differently
as though our language is less important
when we are not learning our own
traditional language
our own indigenous language
there's that
feeling of
missing something that's part of you
so this inuit-owned learning center is
working to prevent their language from
languishing by bringing inuktitut into
the digital age it was a little bit
overwhelming this teacher took on the
daunting task of translating microsoft
and facebook apps into inuktitut the
painstaking process began back in 2005
involving thousands of words some had to
be shortened others needed to be
invented facebook comment for example
there's even a new word for email emails
were sent so immediately by press of a
button so immediate means inland
so the term inlane knocked out was
chosen the result inuktitut is now part
of microsoft's translator app so now
when you speak into the microphone the
translation in
appears in text
sorry it's my first lesson the new
facebook interface was also unveiled
this month we're all on facebook you
know on regular basis the more we put
our language into language on internet
uh the no the more
of a norm it will be in decades for
future children a language the
residential school system sought to
destroy is not only surviving but
evolving for the next generation
and that is global national for this
wednesday night i'm jeff semple we leave
you now with more of pope francis's much
anticipated arrival here in quebec city
his latest stop on the penitential
piglets through canada thanks for
watching hope to see you again tomorrow
good night from quebec city
[Music]
you